- [Voiceover] At the
Constitutional Convention of 1787,
the proposal to replace the existing
Articles of Confederation
with a federal constitution
were met with fierce opposition.
So, what's off here is what was met
with fierce opposition?
Well, the proposal,
the proposal to replace
the existing Articles of Confederation
with a federal constitution.
The proposal is what is being met
with fierce opposition.
Now the proposal, this is clearly,
we're talking about one
proposal, the proposal.
This is right over here
is singular, singular.
While this right over,
they're saying were met.
Well, one thing, you wouldn't use were,
if you're talking about a singular thing
that's it's happening to,
that it's being met with.
So this right over here,
this verb is for plural.
This is for if we had many proposals.
If this said, the proposals
to replace the existing
Articles of Confederation were
met with fierce opposition,
then that would make sense.
But this needs to be singular.
So let's look at the options.
So we definitely don't like it as is,
so let's rule that out.
And so let's see if we can see one
that is where the verb
matches the singular noun.
So let's see, at the
Constitutional Convention of 1787,
the proposal, and you know, we could even
for the sake of kind
of thinking about this,
we can ignore to replace the existing
Articles of Confederation
with a federal constitution
So the proposal having been
met with fierce opposition.
Well, once again, now
it's not even giving us
an action for the proposal.
It's leaving us hanging.
It's a sentence fragment,
there's no predicate.
So we can rule this one out.
The proposal it met
with fierce opposition.
Well now it's giving us
a noun and then a pronoun
to refer to the same thing.
So that doesn't make any sense.
The proposal met with fierce opposition.
That looks pretty good.
Now let's just read it
out, the whole thing.
At the Constitutional Convention of 1787,
the proposal to replace the existing
Articles of Confederation
with a federal constitution
met with fierce opposition.
So that seems exactly right.
A single proposal can be
met with fierce opposition.
You wouldn't say were met with.
So this seems right.
Now let's just look at this last one.
The proposal met their fierce opposition.
So who's their referring to.
They're not talking
about, this is ambiguous.
Who is this protagonist?
This possessive pronoun their.
I don't even see who it's referring to.
So let's rule that one out.
So we definitely like D.